I actually think that people are happy
that you quit your job because it counts
you out of the race because the
likelihood that you win is so low and so
they're happy because you literally take
a step back in income take a step back
in status because you're not doing as
well like I went from a white collar job
to you know being a personal trainer
like it was a big step back so any of my
peer group were like oh yeah so good
that you're doing that right if I had
immediately jumped and started a tech
startup and raised $100 million they
probably immediately wouldn't have been
happy for me your success reminds them
of the dreams that they didn't pursue to
begin with